à Ajay
Est arrivé
fais-le
[musique]
J'ai compris quelque chose à chaque fois qu'on mangeait des frites
N'est-ce pas, je le savais
C'est pourquoi nous le sauvegardons comme ça
C'est ainsi que nous comprenons qu'un être humain est comme quelqu'un
Cela nous sauve, nous les maintenons en vie en les sauvant.
est-ce que c'est
Est arrivé
Faites une grande chose que les gens ne connaissent pas.
Je lui ai fait prendre conscience en allant vers lui.
J'ai dit au comité que ceux qui auraient été pêcheurs maintenant
Quand ils sont assis de chaque côté des eunuques
qui ne l'appelle pas partout
Prenons rendez-vous maintenant et faisons-lui savoir.
Frère, c'est maintenant une nouvelle race dans notre Sind.
Est trouvé et n'est nulle part ami
[musique]
fais-le
Dis m'en plus!